Eldon ring has finally gotten its DLC
announce but all we have is this
beautiful screenshot so here's a short
video breakdown the DLC is described as
an expansion I.E big and it is called
the shadow of the earth tree in the
image we see the error tree being
wrapped and crushed by a second tree
leaking golden sap and there's falling
debris like there was an immediate
tightening but what is this second
hostile treat well maybe it's a or the
Halligan tree after all we see what is
almost certainly mikola in the
foreground riding what seems to be
torrent surrounded by ghost Graves wheat
fields and ruins mikola looks at the
arboreal Carnage over a vast black plane
I talked about Michelob last video and
we saw the DLC could be about death and
maybe in nikola's dream now this image
could be of the past but the landscape
doesn't fit the lanes between and
shouldn't there be some record of such
an erdry shattering event so I think
this is Nicola's dream but maybe inside
it will be able to affect the outside
world we'll have to wait for more info
or a trailer to say anything else so
subscribe if you're looking forward to
that and thanks for watching this video
about how